les projets et demie du matin c'est une
des deux ailes d'un étage c'est l'autre
au delà le cri du coeur mis en ligne par
cette aide de service a ému des milliers
d'internautes chaque nuit depuis deux
semaines amina qu'il est jir avale ses
larmes en cours dans les couloirs d'un
sachet samedi j'aurai sans doute et
reste une impuissance de frustration
j'ai envie que les gens qui ont pris les
décisions qui font en sorte qu on en est
l'homme et venant soit avec moi sur mon
plancher en train de faire ce que je
fais en train de m'aider à sauver des
gens que je peux poursuivre et tout seul
m'aider à les nourrir et qu'ils soient
sur tout témoin que c'est pas démontré
que ce que dénoncent les gens serrières
cette impuissance delphine bergeron la
connaît bien
elle donne aussi un coup de main anciens
chais celle des depuis deux semaines il
ya des soins que ce qui donne pas le
besoin de confort qu'on appelle ça fait
un mois qu'il peut de bain le même temps
c'est triste mais en même temps on n'a
pas le choix parce que le cse la crise
pulls et les gens meurent ce montréalais
a interrompu sa formation de préposés
aux bénéficiaires pour mettre tout de
suite l'épaule à la roue du travail
jusqu'à 16 heures défilé et c'est
difficile pour moi parce que je suis au
début je n'ai jamais travaillé dans ce
domaine
c'est difficile mais ça va quand même
les emplois ne sont pas suffisamment
prospère et il ya des places vides en
manque encore beaucoup d'employés le
premier ministre affirme pourtant que
les effectifs sont suffisants dans
l'essai chez celles des en plus des
militaires 8000 québécois sont venus
prêter main forte
françois legault demande encore des
volontaires cette fois pour leur donner
un répit y a pas de situation y manque
d'employés par contre il ya des employés
le haut c'est fait on commence la
huitième semaine intensive
donc il ya en option fatigué expérience
au coeur de la crise confirme les pires
craintes de plusieurs
personnellement je ferai tout pour pas
envoyer mes parents ses achats soldés
puis ça je pensais ça avant la crise
mais est-ce que j'en aurai les moyens ce
que je plongerai dans la pauvreté comme
beaucoup de da aidé à domicile
probablement le pire scénario pour elle
serait qu aucune leçon ne soit tiré une
fois la tempête passée ici genève garon
radio canada montréal